-Welcome! Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys,
let's get to some news here.
TikTok just announced
that all users under 18
will soon have their accounts
automatically set to
a one-hour daily
screen-time limit.
[ Crowd boos ]
A TikTok limit is rough.
Pretty soon,
kids will be forced to watch
slightly longer videos
on YouTube.
I mean that --
What is the world coming to?
But this is nice.
Facebook said, "If you need help
making kids quit your app,
let us know."
Some political news.
Today, a bipartisan group
of lawmakers
reintroduced a bill to make
Daylight Savings Time permanent.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Man, if Biden gets this done,
there's no way
he's losing in 2024.
I'm telling you.
I have no idea what that is.
Get rid of that thing.
"It's for the farmers."
Like, "No, it's not."
-No.
-They go, "It's for kids."
You go, "No one knows why
we're doing this."
An extra hour.
Right now, every kid's like,
"Sweet.
We're gonna get
an extra hour of TikTok.
Awesome!"
All they have to do is
get Apple on board,
because whatever time my iPhone
says it is, that's the time.
Hey, I saw that House Democrats
are currently in Baltimore
on a retreat where they're
trying to outline
a winning strategy for 2024.
Check out what some of them had
to say about the big retreat.
First up,
Congressman Josh Harder said...
Congressman --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congressman Colin Allred said...
Then Congresswoman
Susan Wild said...
Buck wild.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then Congressman Ed Case said...
Then Congressman
Jared Huffman said...
Then Congresswoman
Lisa Blunt Ro--
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Lisa Blunt Rochester said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then Congresswoman
Deborah Ross said...
And, finally, Congressman
Dan Goldman said...
But, anyway,
they had a fun time.
That was -- [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah!
Some more political news.
Today was the first big day
of speeches at the
Conservative Political Action
Conference, CPAC.
Of course, President Trump --
former president Trump
is attending CPAC.
However, a lot of other
top Republicans aren't.
But Trump said that's because...
Trump was like,
"You can't repeat yourself.
That's why
my campaign slogan is..."
"Don't repeat yourself.
Don't do it."
Actually,
Trump's excited to be there.
He actually spent all day
in the lobby
signing copies of
his classified documents.
-Oh.
-Yeah, it was cool.
Switching gears,
some entertainment news.
The third season
of "The Mandalorian"
just premiered, and --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We all love Baby Yoda,
but now everyone's talking about
another fan-favorite character.
Here, take a look at this guy.
-The insolence.
♪♪
-What do you want?
-"What do you want?"
Apparently,
the clip is so popular,
it even inspired
a number-1 dance remix.
Here now is the video for the
new track "What Do You Want?"
♪ What do you want? ♪
♪♪
-♪ Can you fix it ♪
-♪ What do you want? ♪
-♪ Without the memory circuit? ♪
-♪ Can you ♪
♪ What do you want? ♪
-♪ Fix it ♪
-♪ What do you want? ♪
-♪ Can you fix it ♪
-♪ Huh ♪
-♪ He said he can't fix it ♪
-♪ Okay ♪
-♪ I got it ♪
-♪ He said he can't, he said he
can't, he said he can't ♪
-[ Groans ]
-♪ What do you want? ♪
-♪ I got it ♪
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"What do you want?"
Did you guys see this?
Today, SpaceX launched a crew to
the International Space Station
after the first attempt earlier
this week was cancelled
due to a clogged filter.
Yeah, it's the first time
a space agency
dealt with someone by
calling in the pool guy.
"Trace, you want to take
a look at this?"
"Do I gotta put my shirt on?"
"Hell no."
Yep, a clogged filter.
It's always fun
when a launch delay
can be fixed by someone going...
Speaking of flight issues,
I heard that
a Spirit Airlines plane
had to make an emergency landing
after a battery in
the overhead bin caught on fire.
Spirit was like, "Phew!
Good thing it wasn't
one of our wooden planes."
Wow.
Yeah, the fire was
either caused by a battery
or the pilot was playing with
firecrackers
in the cockpit again.
They got to hire better people.
Listen to this.
Dictionary.com just added
over 300 new words.
That seems like a lot.
And it might explain some other
changes they made, too.
Take a look at this commercial.
-Dictionary.com
is adding 300 new words
to its online database,
such as...
And to make room
for these new additions,
we're eliminating words
that everyone hates, such as...
-Alright, interesting
Isn't that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, hey, this is fun.
Today is National Read Across
America Day.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, shout-out to everyone
who's got me on
with subtitles right now.
Hey, you're awesome.
Yeah, it's National Read Across
America Day,
so I thought we could
maybe go around
and each share
a book recommendation.
-Yeah.
-I'll go first, okay?
I love "Tomorrow, and Tomorrow,
and Tomorrow"
by Gabrielle Zevin.
I highly recommend it.
How about you, Tariq?
-I gotta go with good old
"Fahrenheit 451."
-Oh.
-It's a classic dystopian tale
of, you know,
the dangers of censorship.
-Oh yeah, that's a good one.
That's a good one. Higgins?
-You know what?
I like Tolstoy's "War & Peace."
I know it's long,
but it's worth it.
-"War & Peace."
I've still got to
check that one out.
What about you, James?
-Oh, man!
Oh, my favorite book is
"Dr. Schmoyo's Freaky Froyo
Factory" by Todd Nutbush.
This book has it all, Jimmy --
humor, romance, thrills,
pure carnal sex...
[ Laughter ]
...frozen-yogurt recipes,
and heartbreak.
I couldn't stop crying
while reading it.
I thought to myself,
"Is someone chopping onions?"
Sure enough,
my friend Smooth Jeffrey
was cutting some Vidalia onions
in the same room.
You see, I currently live
with a roommate
because I lost most of my
savings on NFTs.
But not those NFTs.
I'm talking...
[ Laughter ]
N-- Shut up.
Nice-fitting top hats.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow! Wow!
-What?
-Smooth Jeffrey said
I look like a leprechaun,
so I've been working
on my accent.
Check it out.
[ Irish accent ] They're always
trying to steal me Irish cereal.
What do you think?
Yeah, I probably won't be
getting a call from
"Mad TV" anytime soon.
LOL.
Anyway, happy St. Patrick's Day.
[ Irish accent ] Don't forget to
read a book today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow. Is he okay?
-I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I read that
two people in Texas
were just arrested
for allegedly running
an organized
scented-candle-theft ring.
Yeah, and like
all candle-related crimes,
they called in John Wick.
-Oh!
♪♪
-And, finally, three engineers
broke a world record
after they made a paper airplane
that flew almost 300 feet.
Right now,
Spirit Airlines is like,
"Ah, why didn't
we think of paper?!"
There is nothing better
than surprising James
with cue cards during the show,
a live show.
Thank you for being a
good sport, James.
What a show we have
for you tonight.
I love this guy.
-I love this guy.
-He's unbelievable.
He's nominated for an
Academy Award for his role in
"The Whale," which is in
theaters and on demand now.
Brendan Fraser is here tonight.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's a good man.
Plus, the new season of
his show, "Next in Fashion,"
begins streaming
tomorrow on Netflix.
Fashion expert of
"Queer Eye's" Fab Five,
Tan France is joining us!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we got great music
from Lizzy McAlpine,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
She's great.
I've been doing a lot of press
for "That's My Jam."
"That's My Jam" --
season two premieres Tuesday.
I've been doing press.
I've been doing a lot of
radio interviews and TV
interviews and stuff like that.
And this morning,
I was on one of our pal's,
"Elvis Duran
and The Morning Show."
And I went on there --
I love him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, Danielle, hi, Gandhi.
A great crew over there.
And they wanted to play a game,
and they said,
"This is such a dumb game
that we're playing."
And I go, "I love dumb games.
What is it?"
And it's called,
"I'm thinking of a pasta."
[ Laughter ]
That's the name of the game.
And I go, "Okay."
And, so, the whole idea is,
Elvis was just thinking of
a pasta, and I had to guess.
So I thought -- I said,
"I want to take that game.
I want to play it on
'The Tonight Show,'"
and he goes, "You'd be out of
your mind to take that game."
And I am out of my mind,
so here we go.
We're gonna play the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's do it.
So, I want to play the game.
Higgins, Tariq, Questlove,
you want to play with me?
I'm gonna write down a pasta.
-Okay.
-I'm thinking of a pasta, okay?
Eh-huh, mm-huh, mm-huh.
[ Laughter ]
Mm-huh, mm.
-Wait a second.
-I don't want
to give anything away.
All right.
Now, here we go.
I'm thinking of a pasta.
Questlove, what pasta --
Oh, how 'bout this?
If you guess it right,
everyone in the audience
gets a pint of
Tonight Dough Ben & Jerry
ice cream.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm just saying!
You want to let
these people down?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, man.
Come on, dude!
All right.
I'm thinking of a pasta.
-Man, that's a lot of pressure.
-I'm thinking of a pasta.
Here we go.
-Whoa.
-All right.
And it falls on me to guess it.
-Well, we have you, Tariq,
and then Higgins, yeah.
But I'm thinking of a pasta.
-All right.
I'll go easy.
I'll say rigatoni.
-Ooh!
-Not true.
Not good, not good.
It is not rigatoni.
Thank you very much.
Come on, focus up.
Tariq?
[ Laughter ]
I am thinking of a pasta.
-Okay. Okay.
I'm gonna say, uh...
fusilli.
-Ooh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-What are you talking about?
Fusilli?
You thought that's the pasta
I'm --
-Because you're silly.
I figured silly, fusilli.
All right, whatever, man.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm thinking of a pasta!
Higgins, we've known each other
for 25 years.
You are Italian.
-Yes.
-You've been to Italy.
-We've shared many a meal
together.
I'm thinking of a pasta,
and the audience
is getting ice cream
if you guess it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Higgins,
I'm thinking of a pasta.
-I'm gonna say, since
you've played this once before,
you probably did a fancy one
like fusilli.
And I'm gonna say you're
gonna go, like, every day --
I'm gonna say penne.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Penne!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
That was it! Penne!
Oh, buddy.
-Come on! Come on!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I said!
Penne!
Everyone's going home
with some ice cream!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who likes ice cream?
[ Laughs ]
-Whoo!
-Ah. I love you, Elvis.
Alright, guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So since my show "That's My Jam"
is premiering next week, I went
on Twitter and sent out
the #ThatsMyJam.
And I asked you guys to send in
some funny or weird things that
you like to do,
things that are your jam.
Within minutes, it was a
trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite #ThatsMyJam
tweets from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from
@71meliwoe. She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do that. That's my jam.
I do it too.
"Moo, moo, moo!"
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @jaco0721.
-Mm!
-They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from
@explaurenaround. She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice.
Nice.
-This one's from @ramandwildcat.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-That's your jam?
-That's their jam.
This one's from
@pierrelafrance0. He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is our jam.
We all have that.
-We all got that.
-This one's from @djtheoldman.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Take the "W." A win's a win.
This one's from @ubiquitousbdog.
They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Speak. Speak.
Habla. Habla."
Last one from @notloggedin.
She says...
That's my jam. That's correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you have it. Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
"That's My Jam,"
Tuesday night, 10:00.
We'll be right back with
Brendan Fraser. Come on back.